[Music]
in the summer of 1997 NASA's Pathfinder
spacecraft landed on the surface of Mars
and began transmitting incredible iconic
images back to earth
but several days in something went
terribly wrong the transmissions stopped
Pathfinder was in effect procrastinating
keeping itself fully occupied but
failing to do its most important work
what was going on there was a bug it
turned out in its scheduler every
operating system has something called
the scheduler that tells the CPU how
long to work on each task before
switching and what to switch to done
right Computers move so fluidly between
their various responsibilities they give
the illusion of doing everything
simultaneously but we all know what
happens when things go wrong this should
give us if nothing else some measure of
consolation even computers get
overwhelmed sometimes maybe learning
about the computer science of scheduling
can give us some ideas about our own
human struggles with time one of the
first insights is that all the time you
spend prioritizing your work is time you
aren't spending doing it for instance
let's say when you check your inbox you
scan all the messages choosing which is
the most important once you've dealt
with that one you repeat seem sensible
but there's a problem here this is
what's known as a quadratic time
algorithm with an inbox that's twice as
full these passes will take twice as
long and you'll need to do twice as many
of them this means four times the work
the programmers of the operating system
Linux encountered a similar problem in
2003 Linux would rank every single one
of its tasks in order of importance and
sometimes spent more time ranking tasks
than doing them the programmers
counterintuitive solution was to replace
this full ranking with a limited number
of prior
buckets the system was less precise
about what to do next but more than made
up for it by spending more time making
progress so with your emails insisting
on always doing the very most important
thing first could lead to a meltdown
waking up to an inbox three times fuller
than normal could take nine times longer
to clear you'd be better off replying in
chronological order or even at random
surprisingly sometimes giving up on
doing things in the perfect order may be
the key to getting them done another
insight that emerges from computer
scheduling has to do with one of the
most prevalent features of modern life
interruptions when a computer goes from
one task to another it has to do what's
called a context switch bookmarking its
place in one task moving old data out of
its memory and new data in each of these
actions comes at a cost the insight here
is that there's a fundamental trade-off
between productivity and responsiveness
getting serious work done means
minimizing context switches but being
responsive means reacting anytime
something comes up these two principles
are fundamentally in tension recognizing
this tension allows us to decide where
we want to strike that balance the
obvious solution is to minimize
interruptions the less obvious one is to
group them if no notification or email
requires a response our more urgently
than once an hour say then that's
exactly how often you should check them
no more in computer science this idea
goes by the name of interrupt coalescing
rather than dealing with things as they
come up
oh the mouse was moved a key was pressed
more of that file downloaded the system
groups these interruptions together
based on how long they can afford to
wait in 2013 interrupt coalescing
triggered a massive improvement in
laptop battery life this is because
deferring interruptions
system check everything at once then
quickly re-enter a low-power state as
with computers so it is with us
perhaps adopting a similar approach
might allow us users to reclaim our own
attention and give us back one of the
things that feels so rare in modern life
rest are you interested in improving
your own time and task management skills
if so we highly recommend you check out
algorithms to live by the computer
science of human decisions you can
download an audio version of the book
for free at audible.com slash ted-ed
and every free trial created encourages
audible to continue supporting Ted Ed's
nonprofit mission
[Music]